hey everyone I'm Francesca if you're in
genie with aj+ you might remember me
from such as the real deal with a
us-mexico border Louisiana sinking and
the time I rolled business leaders at
the Paris climate summit and if you
haven't seen me around much that's
because I've been o seeing news broke
aj+ is comedy channel act like you know
dude
Donald Trump is a ShamWow guy of
President oh it's been a rough year for
me America the decision on the Dakota
access pipeline might very well land in
the lap of a man who's been compared to
Andrew Jackson hello Trump of Spears
you've seen that right every Friday the
news broke team brings you in-depth
reporting with fart jokes also sketches
like this little hit white privilege
might seem like everything is easier all
the time and it is but it can also be
hard because feelings are hard just
listen to what the internet is already
saying about news broke you guys are
amazing
best newest channel on YouTube love this
channel this is the most underrated
YouTube channel ever are you controlled
by Jews like all the Western media so
watch us on our YouTube channel at WWE
youtube.com slash news broke what does
the C stand for u.s. stands for comedy
and China
it stands for neither of those things we
just couldn't get to see removed so
click right here to be transported to
the world of news broke a world where
you get to see me every single week
[Music]